in frankreich haben sie gelesen in
frankreich dürfen die bürger neuerdings
ihren präsidentschaftskandidaten
bestimmen
so belegt man demokratie deutschland
munkelt weiter vor sich hin
wo soll das noch hinführen wir haben
hier für sie und fragen sie mich bitte
nicht wie wir das technisch hinkriegen
schau mal eine heute show ein ausschnitt
einer heute show aus dem jahr 2021 so
viel vom dritten weltkrieg hätte das
gedacht dass der erdogan wirklich
österreich angreift naja dietmar
wischmeyer blickt jetzt für uns zurück
auf die letzten vier jahre angela merkel
[Musik]
kinder wie die zeit vergeht schon wieder
vier jahre merkel rum und was hat die
frau nicht alles bewegt im goldenen
herbst ihrer kanzlerschaft
unvergessliche bilder wie damals bei der
hochzeit von trump und putin mit merkel
als brautjungfer
was haben wir gefeiert hoch emotional
auf das lang ersehnte ende des euro 2017
und die einführung des sanifair bons als
offizielle deutsche währung angela
merkel hat eine zerrissene gesellschaft
wieder geeint den aufstieg der afg zu
verhindern
begrüßt sind nun einmal die woche
abgehängte globalisierungs verlierer im
kanzleramt eine schöne geste
sie war es den islam endgültig in die
deutschen leitkultur integriert hat hier
sehen wir sie am ramadan mit einem
muslimischen kinderchor
nur dank unserer ewigen kanzlerin bleibt
deutschland innovationsstandort numero
uno
erinnert sei hier nur an der einführung
des vollautomatischen bundespräsidenten
damit in der schweiz bald theater
endlich aufhört und natürlich die
entwicklung der riesen mandarin im jahr
2020 deutschland sagt danke für 16
wundervolle jahre an die regierungszeit
der wohl erfolgreichsten uckermärkern
aller zeiten erinnert schon jetzt dass
merkel an ihm in hamburg mit dem
propheten aller besiegten
spd-kanzlerkandidaten holt rio all die
jahre haben wir nichts anhaben können
umso größer die freude als merkel diese
woche vor die presse trat um zu
verkünden
ich trete noch mal an hurra bis 2025
bitte jemand erschießen
[Musik]
neuer
aus dem jahr 2021
[Applaus]